[Music]
foreign
so it has been quite a while since we
saw the short tears of Godzilla minus
one and between then and now there have
been many arumas regarding the Big G
that would be seen this November well
December in the states the most
controversial and most gossip about is
the presence of another monster in the
movie and to be most specific another
Godzilla there have been leaked plots
circulating around 4chan and Reddit
about the general theme of the movie and
while these are to be taken with a grain
of salt one couldn't help but wonder if
the birds are really chirping the
truthful chime so here in this video we
will address the rumors and discuss what
they really are
so let's first start with talking about
what we have seen in the teaser in a
couple of sentences Godzilla minus one
will be the first live-action Touhou
Godzilla movie since the critically
acclaimed Shin Gojira of 2016. it
promises to bring back the horror and
Terror that the original 1954 Godzilla
brought to the screens it will be
settled around both war Japan in the
1940s and maybe stretch on to the early
1950s as well the Godzilla we saw in the
teaser lives up to the hype it was seen
rampaging across a Japanese City
wreaking havoc and about to munch on a
train just like the original did in the
very first movie the Godzilla will be
around 60 meters or 200 feet tall or if
not less since the producers aim for a
Kaiju that can actually have a
believable interaction with the people
of the nation of Japan it looks to be
more spiky and rough in texture with a
menacing face and a personality that
matches its looks so with that out of
the way let's take a look at these
theories
the two Godzilla theory is something
that has been swimming around various
sites gaining traction and to be honest
we don't really know if it has a solid
foundation oh it's just a
hyper-enthusiastic fan claiming to know
about the plot and then things just got
out of hand and from then on it just
became bigger than life let's say but it
actually wouldn't be that unrealistic it
wouldn't be the first time we see two
Godzillas in the same movie the very
first time Mechagodzilla entered the
screens he was disguised as Godzilla
himself then there is space Godzilla
versus Godzilla and if you count the
baby Godzilla and Manila then that makes
for another couple of movies heck even
the monster verse did that in 2014
although here it's dagon's dead body and
then the Big G later in the film so what
I'm saying is that it's not really that
far-fetched okay now let's take a look
at the different theories
the first one is the one Godzilla 2
forms Theory this will be like an
evolution plotline like shin Gojira here
Godzilla might make landfall in Tokyo or
some other City just after the nuclear
bombings and then return back to the Sea
only to reappear again after a few years
when Japan has started to rebuild and
return to normal this time he will
appear as a bigger more evil entity that
has been driven to kill Humanity for
upsetting its underwater home with
nuclear waste dumping and then slowly he
will begin to take on another even
deadlier form even bigger one forcing
the Japanese Defense Force to react and
alongside shirazawa develop the oxygen
Destroyer weapon to kill the G-Man just
like in the very first movie did it
after all state that this will be some
sort of a reboot of the original so in
order to stay true to the OG The
Starlight must unfold the same way
the second theory is the two Godzillas
the good and evil Theory so the origin
of this information seems to be a 4chan
or Reddit pose it suggests that the
movie -1 is a reimagining of the
original 1954 Godzilla film Gojira in
this version The Story diverges by
having Godzilla appear right after the
atomic bombs are dropped instead of the
Lucky Dragon incident that happened in
the 1950s the truth is that there might
be two Godzillas of the same species but
with differences one will resemble a
familiar scar dinosaur like Godzilla
while the other is described as not
being affected by nuclear energy or
radiation this version has proportions
similar to an orca having a smooth skin
and a prominent dorsal fin-like plate
maybe it's the one that has been teased
in the poster it also will possess a
tale reminiscent of the Pokemon Mewtwo
but adapted for Aquatic Life the film
May delve deeper into the perspectives
of these creatures and it is expected to
have a tragic ending as the Scott
Godzilla wreaks havoc on the surface
World in Japan the other Godzilla will
try to guide it back to its natural
habitat but then one of them might die
or maybe both of them
the third theory is the one Godzilla the
godzillasaurus and the Godzilla Theory
so here during the Pacific War in 1944
on lagus island both the Japanese and
American Forces fight each other and
then encounter a godzillasaurus the
creature will defend its territory and
also help the Japanese repelling the
Americans but getting injured in the
process so unlike the heisei plot of
time travel and all those future and
stuff
here are the godzillasaurus would
somehow be affected by nuclear testings
later right after 1945 and then mutated
to become the terror of Japan Godzilla
he would also have resentment and a
desire to take revenge on Humanity for
turning him into a terrifying creature
hence the overarching theme of nuclear
testings and its dangerous effects this
Godzilla will start destroying towns and
cities in Japan while the Defense Forces
of the country will have to plead help
with the U.S to use another nuke to kill
the Kaiju this one I believe makes the
least sense out of all three
so as to what mindq really believes
Godzilla minus one would be just like
the original a respectful re-rendition
or reboot of the first ever film it will
have motion capture and CGI instead of a
man in a suit that's for sure but this
one will be seen from different
perspectives and angles capturing the
terror of what it would be like to be a
Japanese citizen during a monster attack
and at the same time give Justice to
Godzilla's character who has always
began his career as a monster a
horror-inducing force of nature that is
beyond Humanity's control
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel take care
fam